some people clamoring for the pvp pvp or
riot or your friend WP I want the PvP
that's a crucible I'd be damned yeah
we'll be able to bust out the original
m4 again is the game balances oh yeah
Ben then there's iron banner mode right
yeah yeah iron banner is different and
we need to get some new ships we haven't
got tired of matching you guys man yeah
it's getting real weird
it's getting really color coordination
thing better coast
Oh guys I'm a little pumped right now
this seems like a good place for
vacation you thought this was all lost
an anus hi Venus baby oh yeah
you [ __ ] right here that's right boys
and girls no oh you look at that rank of
that rain able to get the lay of the
land that's tight like if you look up
you get like kind of like water drops on
your vomit yeah no actually really cool
it's really cool
subtle all right let's clouds man oh you
guys can spawn vehicle
yeah at all nope oh no they got Venus
unblocked but in this location pesum
worst doo doo horse to do oh you got
that cloak or did you guys just like are
you guys too far ahead that I can see
you're trying to hide where haha put a
bunch of ass let's ditch a holy mummy to
see your your nametag over it you guys
should he spotted us oh man yeah your
chance summon is this the last verse I
mean us
oh [ __ ] dick level 10 drags
I think the Vandals got blue army now
what's up careful because it's an ended
well and we're all set with you well
we're all eight right I'm centered okay
don't know I mean okay so there's a two
levels oh there's a green item I got to
go for it keep pushing out I'll catch up
I just want to make sure that I got a
smattering full Engram Reese what's we
gone this way
now tase ditching us Power Move the
bunch of dudes over there but yeah Venus
is tight ma'am I said we have a change
of scenery
yeah for sure a little sick of the moon
already yeah
Oh short live we're making some real
wild card moves you mean by running up
in a wizard punch chittering you're the
one telling us to be careful yeah
everybody be careful while I rush in
well somebody's doing kind of punching
the vanduul there you go I'm sorry guys
go turbo veto single butts I'm two point
faster no I was holding square harder
than you were this way the vehicle link
yeah ding clear just got me way guys
guys a lot of worship of X now what are
we going I know find the Guardian
outposts I don't need to find it I'll
just follow Dinklage Beck sensors it's
up
and I really keep having to stop myself
from pressing X while I'm on this thing
Oh
right here's wild our vehicle that's
right
quick flash oh yeah oh there's a man
hiding back here what I was wondering
with those no they won't they won't see
them they won't see me they don't have
radar only we're going the wrong way
are we yeah but that cave down there
looks cool I know ya doing there
these suckers stupid other than that
tree thing
what up drags oh there's a servitor
inside just threw a flashbang in there
just step on that a bully
good snap that servitor and mantels take
way more shots now I got some spirit
blue don't know what that be
and your giant blue I guess totally wild
card [ __ ]
Aries we found the next spot and deploy
it haha gotchu oh yeah he's a master of
holding down at square yeah for sure
these sensors are you know you guys can
be just as good as me someday all the
hair man one day you'll be as good as I
said killing with my hair power well
just like mashing X that was the door
doesn't even open we have to leave now
why would they send us to a door to
press a button I'll watch it
Roode sends abby's well maybe you should
get on your vehicle faster oh that's a
tree an outpoint
oh now we're going back to where we were
Erol okay I shouldn't have run in there
like that yeah you know you don't punch
available to learn that the hard way I
punch it a vandal punches right though
do you always punch a drag no worries
there oh guys hiding in love the rigs Oh
stab me alright guys I got a little
cocky with the punches this isn't Call
of Duty okay oh not a one-hit kill
thought it was here we now we're going
to the cave thing
we had to go away from it just for every
reason i'm animos man come on in the
hose
we need to collect ten rat Momo's scans
first oh oh there's a chest here sweet
golden chest Oh new gun what is it
I don't it's an auto rifle green one I
just got one of those you just bought
one though I got one mission reward I'll
try it it's the exact same weapon at a
slightly higher stability but otherwise
it's a level so yeah when I can just
sell the old one I guess believe
different where are you guys all trying
it at the same time now I I like my
scout rifle guys my radars blowing up
around this corner good yeah
could be all this weird lightning look
this a team just talked out of man look
at that [ __ ] what is it let me get a
closer look
he's a closer look at your fish dark all
of it it's fun
the structure of light oh that's kind of
cool that's good do a deploy it goes to
your I'm pretty good at that I don't
know I thought that was no yeah we
totally do it's so bright I couldn't
even see that I look for chests while
you're doing that conflict this is the
actual library soon this this is the
library this is a very on extremes oh no
it's the vex
what ever goblins
hey new units Dinklage slowly came after
like robotic robotic with no yablans
that's not what I expected pretty said
guide screw it all wrong well that is
yeah that's not it
oh crap that it's not got one yeah yeah
that's not a robot
hola need help
oh no I just died yeah where are you
behind you guys there's one behind this
boy I'm gonna provide you rang I'm up
good well I just know dude we're going
in
oh nice Hobgoblin
oh and behind this the angle yeah
there's a big it's a terminator 2
minutes work sorry
they have like a mythical names for all
these robots good so you can shoot them
in the head I shot his head still and he
still walks around yeah you guys called
a minute or no he sort of lost its hair
so splashed him his armors off I'm out
of little toward day it was a bunch of
bullets over others more coming I think
Oh
well top two
all right you guys use your special
abilities lady
nice
yeah the goblins can lose their heads
too and still fight yeah they do they
charge at you more from that same spot
with a humble f warping and oh yeah
they're working
that's mine
yeah up top left side
oh you got me three that they are yeah
tough on the left
yeah
I'm gonna do it
appreciate it
there's olives mo everywhere yeah
there's more again watch our walk in a
minute or so of course it totally blew
my grenade talk great damage for myself
with thanks
no problem wildcard round keep wildcard
the belly Thank You chat thanks cat oh
my god the Minotaur okay gonna bust up
the machine gun okay actually just
rocket launcher this guy the other day
yet so cool like that oh oh there's
another mandatory on the Atlantic Ocean
or the right sorry
yeah here depending on how you're
looking at it so I'm going to try to get
yeah I don't know dude oh it's totally
not easy are you if he's normally
alright oh you're coming this way that
was like why would you I thought yeah
that's alright Oh
punch me we're in the mouth oh okay
alright get back if you wait oh you go
them done that works too
oh we got it it's done you can tell the
music they're gone it's a cyclops good
work guys what a little hectic but we
got there yeah that's fine
yeah I'm roses grapes down here probably
two hours
that's the Chris waters special and
Berkeley Bowl you're here Oh who's that
we have a baby are you doing hmm
looking pretty good but that thing's
mascot launch I don't even have time to
explain why I don't have time to explain
I know you're gonna have time to explain
there's no time to talk the way you're
talking no time for explanations many
Guardians her mask is sick though okay
when she talks it lights up but you made
it here yes I'm listening
understood
she's like whatever Dinklage thank you
that why you brought us here they
brought us here to vex evil so dark it
despises other evil
you're not a guardian no I was not
forged in light
but I believe where our paths cross
round
have you heard of the black garden is
that another library prop what a library
to us old lies there where these
machines are born
find the black garden rip out its heart
only then will travel to begin to heal
can you help us find it my paths my own
I can't
if we're going to find the black garden
ah yes they woken out their wavering
between the light in the dark aside
should always be taken a little light
even if it's the wrong side I don't know
if that's good advice
yeah I don't know either hold position
kill the engines and don't let the
market whoa see it yep he's like them
I'm at how do we fire a woman they live
all the way out of the edge of the
darkness last place the light touches
can't we just stay here with the
murderous trovelump we're a little light
I wrote this dialogue
what hit mean this was like a one
mission like good job guys you beat
Venus you really did it